Good morning Hank; it’s Wednesday. As you
know, sometimes a Nerdfighter meets another
Nerdfighter and they fall in Nerdfighterlike.
Well, today I present you with four stories
of nerd love in all its many splendors!
Let’s begin with Phil and TJ. Hank, you
may remember that a couple years ago I was
part of a Nerdfighter marriage proposal. Nerdfighter
flashback!
2009 John: Is Phil there with you, by the
way?
TJ: Yes he is.
2009 John: Will you marry him?
TJ: Holy... yes!
2009 John: Yeaaaaah! Hey, she said yes! Gaaah!
2011 John: So Hank, update! Not only are Phil
and TJ happily married, they are expecting
their first child! Huzzah! Woah! Woah woah
woah! It looks like I got so excited about
Phil and TJ’s baby that I had an accident.
And now I am seated in a pool of cheap champagne.
What’s new?
Anyway Hank, TJ has one of the funniest blogs
on the entire internet chronicling this pregnancy
with helpful diagrams of her fetus eating
its feet and stuff. Check it out, Hank, link
in the doobly-doo, although I should note
that that blog does contain frank language.
I mean, to be fair, it’s possible to be
pregnant without cursing, but it’s definitely
not advisable.
Story number two! Conner and Amy. God, there
is a lot of champagne in my pants right now.
Okay, Hank, a boy and his Air Force bear go
into the woods. Hold on. Yeah, I thought that
sentence might be unprecedented. So a boy
and his Air Force bear go into the woods,
and they ask Amy to Homecoming. Then the boy
submits the picture to Eff Yeah Nerdfighters,
they run it, and a few days later she responds:
"Dear Conner, Homecoming sounds beautiful.
I’ll paint my nails electric blue in honor
of Alaska." GAH! Hank, it’s so cute I can
hardly bear it! Get it? Bear it? Because of
the bear! I’m drunk, aren’t I? I’m drunk
because there’s champagne in my chair that’s
traveled into my pants, that’s then gone
through my skin and into my body. I’m not
a scientist, but I believe that’s called
osmosis.
Anyway Hank, they did go to Homecoming, but
you know, that was six months ago, which in
Nerdfighterlike is a long time, and we all
know that every relationship ends, you know:
either breakup, divorce, or death. So, the
update is THEY’RE STILL TOGETHER! Yes!
Story three: My face plus your torso equals
Nerdfighterlike. So Hank, I recently got an
email from Janice, pictured here, in which
she told me that she was wearing her Pizza
John shirt in her Elementary Statistics class
because, you know, what else are you going
to wear to Elementary Statistics? And this
boy Andrew walked up to her and said “Are
you a Nerdfighter?” and she said “Nah,
I just love pizza and men with creeper mustaches”--
No, she said yes, she said "Yes I’m a Nerdfighter."
And then he was like “I’m on my way to
a GAS meeting. The Gaming and Anime Society?
Perhaps you’d like to join me.” And of
course she said yes and now they’re in Nerdfighterlike.
Huzzah!
GAS, the Gaming and Anime Society? Couldn’t
you have called it the Society for Anime and
Gaming? SAG?
Story four: The boy from the bookstore. Okay
Hank, so a few weeks ago a Nerdfighter is
in a Barnes and Noble in Bel Air, Maryland.
She gets to talking to a cute boy, and it
turns out that they are both Nerdfighters,
but then they go their separate ways without
exchanging any kind of contact information!
And then this girl writes us and says "Can
you please help me track down my Nerdfighter
crush?" So listen up! If you are five foot
seven, you have brown hair and blue eyes,
and you were recently in the Bel Air, Maryland
Barnes and Noble talking to a girl about Nerdfighting,
let us know.
Hank, those are my stories of nerd love. I
hope they made you as happy as they made me.
Three other things: first, this shiny little
number, Will Grayson, Will Grayson just came
out in paperback yesterday. If you want to
buy it, there’s a link to do so in the doobly-doo.
Secondly, Nerdfighters, do you have any Nerdfighterlike
stories? If so, leave them in comments. And
finally Hank, your videos about Haiti continue
to be an inspiration to me and to all of Nerdfighteria.
To thank you, I have made a three hundred
dollar gift to Water.org. Nerdfighters, if
you would like to join me in giving and following
our community in Haiti, check out the link
in the doobly-doo.
It occurs to me that there are a lot of links
in the doobly-doo today, but they’re all
good ones! Hank, I’m gonna go change pants.
I’ll see you on Friday.